The number of people rescued from under the rubble
has reached 2470. The
number of buildings found to be destroyed is
2,818.
Since debris removal works continue in many buildings in the earthquake zone, we do not know
how high the number of dead and injured will
rise.
Our hope is that we survived this disaster with the least loss of life.
Help offers from 45 countries, including NATO and the European Union,
have reached us.
So I was asleep. My wife woke me up,
but in a terrible earthquake, not a very severe one,
of course, there was a sound from all sides. It took a
long time. So I
promise about 2 minutes. Right
now, we have brothers who are under the goose.
I had a friend, they already saved him, he
just made his daughter's servant,
what is the situation, I will show the process, let him heal